ever since the discovery of the nag
hamadi library in egypt in 1945
and the subsequent publication of
various non-canonical gospels and other
lost ancient texts there has been an
increased interest in the early history
and development of christianity in
particular there is a growing
fascination with the so-called gnostics
and their alternative interpretation of
biblical scriptures
but since the study of what is often
term gnosticism is still very young
there have emerged many different
perspectives and interpretations on how
this group or groups should be
categorized which texts belong to who
and how they should be understood as a
result there are often many
misconceptions about this topic and its
complexities there's a tendency to
sensationalize and exotify
these things in ways that don't
necessarily align with actual
scholarship
so with this in mind let's take a moment
to look at what the latest scholarship
says on this topic and ask ourselves the
questions who were the gnostics and what
is gnosticism
[Applause]
the term gnostic can be and is used in a
variety of different ways the word
itself comes from the greek term gnosis
meaning knowledge or more often a
specific kind of knowledge or insight
beyond the conceptual
gnosis is frequently used to mean a kind
of intuitive spiritual knowledge as
opposed to everyday information
as such the word gnosis and gnostic has
or had positive connotations in many
circles in antiquity the hermitis for
example talk about gnosis as opposed to
episteme and proto-orthodox christians
like clement of alexandria use the word
to refer to a superior kind of spiritual
or intellectual state and we often see
this broad use of the term today in
scholarly literature various people
across history are called quote-unquote
gnostics on the basis that they are
connected to a supra-rational kind of
knowledge for example islamic mystics or
sufis are often referred to as gnostics
with arabic words like erfan and arif
being possible equivalents but when we
talk about the gnostics or even
gnosticism we are more often using the
word in a specific way as referring to a
movement in early christianity
one that has become famous for its world
neglecting attitudes and very complex
metaphysical scheme
the gnostics represented one tendency
among a multitude of interpretations
after the jesus event
one that eventually disappeared after
the gradual formation of a christian
orthodoxy or official church and which
can differ dramatically from the latter
talking about the gnostics and
gnosticism can be very difficult since
they didn't survive beyond a few
centuries a.d
accessing sources and information about
this topic has been hard the only
sources we had for most of history were
those written by the horesiologists
so proto-christians or later writers
like
irenaeus for example who wrote very
critically about the gnostics and wanted
to sort of
deem them as heretics but in 1945 the
monumental discovery of the nag hammadi
library in egypt revolutionized our
understanding of these groups
the coptic texts found in the library
contain writings by the so-called
gnostics themselves
some of which had been mentioned in the
works of the heresiologist previously
and since then we've been able to get a
much more comprehensive and nuanced
understanding about the ideas and
practices of various early christian
communities and schools of thought
despite this however there is
disagreement among scholars on how
this gnosticism should be categorized
some have opted for a very universalist
approach to gnosticism
which views gnosticism as such as a sort
of
wider religious or spiritual
intellectual movement in antiquity in to
which many different groups belonged so
we talk about specifically christian
groups like the valentinians or the
martianites or the
um the sethians for example as all
belonging to this wider category of
gnosticism these scholars will often
want to include other
non-christian movements or traditions as
gnosticism as well like the mandaeans or
the manichaeans and sometimes even the
hermitis many others will argue that
there was no such thing as gnosticism at
all this is just a modern category that
we anachronistically applied to a
context that was much more complex than
that but many scholars today including
david bracke in his book the gnostics
argue for a kind of middle position with
a much more narrow definition of
gnosticism as a particular school of
thought within the diversity of early
christianity in this episode i will be
following this more narrow definition of
gnosticism talking about the gnostics as
in particular an expression of early
christianity and following scholar david
bracke i will be identifying these
gnostics
especially or particularly with the
group that is often known as the
sethians
while also touching on other related
movements like the valentinians of
course okay so who were the gnostics
then well the first thing to have in
mind here is the well the environment of
early christianity a common way to
present the first few centuries after
jesus's death including by early
christians like irenaeus who is a person
who will return a lot in this discussion
is with a single orthodox church from
which a number of different sects or
heresies diverged
but this as you might imagine is a very
anachronistic way of reading history it
only seems that way from the perspective
of a much later established orthodoxy
looking back at its earliest
developments
now to tell you more about this topic in
particular i've turned to my colleague
and the religious scholar andrew henry
from the channel religion for breakfast
so
is him to tell you more
the discovery of the nag hamadi library
was so important for historians not only
because we discovered previously unknown
works of literature but it also gave us
a glimpse into the social dynamics of
early christianity it sheds some light
on what anti-heresy writers like
irenaeus were trying to accomplish to
illustrate what i mean let's examine the
bishop of alexandria athanasius in 367
ce athanasius published a letter to the
churches in egypt instructing them which
books they're allowed to read he is the
first christian author to apply the term
canon to the same 27 books that most
christians today use in their new
testament he wrote in these books alone
the teaching of piety is proclaimed let
no one add to or subtract from them he
goes on to attack anyone teaching and
preaching from books outside of this
canon what's interesting is that the nag
hammadi codices are roughly
contemporaneous with athanasius
christians right down the road from him
were probably reading and copying these
so-called gnostic books now we might be
tempted to read athanasius's letter as a
top-down decree that drove these
non-canonical writings into hiding in
fact some early christian scholars have
argued that but in a groundbreaking
article the scholar of early
christianity david brackey argued that
rather than writing from a position of
strength athanasius was writing from a
precarious position in a christian
landscape full of different competing
modes of christianity his attempt to
stipulate what books you're allowed to
read reflects more fundamental conflicts
between competing modes of christian
authority spirituality and social
organization in other words we're
getting a glimpse into competing
varieties of how to be christian how to
do christianity during a time when those
questions were not yet definitively
answered on one hand we have varieties
of christianity exemplified by
athanasius who wanted a closed cannon of
books and who organized their authority
around elected bishops and parishes who
derived their authority through
apostolic succession and on the other
hand with the nakamati codices we see
evidence for varieties of christianity
that were disinterested in a closed
canon these were christians who saw no
problem with writing more gospels
christians who were interested in
mystical and philosophical speculation
and when it comes to authority and
social organization we see christians
like the valentinians that formed study
circles around charismatic intellectual
leaders so when we read anti-gnostic
polemics we should remember to situate
them in this historical context a time
when these groups were still thriving
and competing to use an analogy from
david brackey these proto-orthodox
writers had not yet won the horse race
the race was ongoing we're not so much
seeing a battle between a unified
orthodoxy versus splinter cells of
heresies we're seeing varieties of
christianities all attempting to define
their own social group defining the
in-group versus the out-group there's
perhaps no better example of an
anti-gnostic polemicist trying to do
this than the bishop of cyprus
epiphanius in the late 4th century he
wrote a book called the panarion which
is basically a series of essays
attacking several different groups that
he labeled as heretics including the
gnostics in one passage he describes a
whole mess of disgusting rituals that
the gnostics supposedly practiced in
particular epiphanius describes them
engaging in ritualized cannibalism now
no historian thinks any gnostic group
actually did this but his polemic is
useful in shedding some light on what
these heresyologists were trying to do
what epiphanius is doing is inventing
lurid unthinkable stories to try to
socially categorize the gnostics as the
ultimate evil
the history of religions is full of
examples like this as the scholar of
early christianity david frankfurter
argues
accusing your religious rivals of
ritualized sex or cannibalism is an
effective social psychological strategy
to make your opponents easier to attack
easier to expel or ostracize from your
own group and these groups did overlap
many today think of gnosticism as a
secretive or subversive antithesis to
orthodoxy but these groups and ideas
seem to have been out in the open the
christian writer tertullian says that
valentinus was almost elected a bishop
of rome ironia says that valentinians
were attending church groups in his own
social circle the non-commodity codices
themselves suggest that there was a
vibrant intellectual culture to copy and
disseminate these books and collect them
into personal libraries which was not an
inexpensive endeavor someone of a
reasonably high social standing must
have collected them because there were
so few christians at the time people
like athanasius and epiphanius were
probably acutely aware of their
differences and fought back hard against
them trying to define their preferred
mode of christianity this is why
scholars today prefer to call all of
these groups labeled under gnosticism as
varieties of early christianity rather
than buying into the binary of orthodoxy
versus heresy varieties highlights the
massive diversity of christianity at the
time and highlights the fact that no one
was guaranteed victory at the time
back to you philip dr henry is a scholar
of religion who specializes in early
christianity he runs the youtube channel
religion for breakfast which is one of
the best channels on youtube when it
comes to religion so if you haven't
checked that out you should definitely
go check out his channel and subscribe
to it he has some excellent material on
the gnostics in particular if you are
interested in knowing
more about that topic
the model of a single true church from
which heresies diverged has long been
abandoned by scholars but neither should
we see it as a group of fixed
quote-unquote schools all competing in a
race for authority there wasn't a
unified group of proto-orthodox that
remained unchanged and eventually won
but a diverse intermingling of ideas
interpretations and theological
positions
certainly certain social groups were
formed in clusters of similar
interpretations emerged in the early
centuries but all these individuals and
schools influenced each other and
contributed to the gradual development
that resulted in the eventual formation
of an orthodox church this great
diversity is reflected in the corpus of
texts found at nag hamadi and otherwise
which appear to come from a multitude of
different early christian movements
you have texts that would eventually
become part of the orthodox canon like
the four gospels of mark matthew luke
and john etc but we also find texts that
belong to the gnostic school of thought
like the secret book of john and the
gospel of judas
there are texts like the gospel of truth
which seems to come from the
valentinians and even treatises like the
gospel of thomas which appears to come
from another christian movement
altogether
in other words there were many different
christianities at this time most of whom
produced many different texts
the gnostics seemed to have been one of
the most influential of these movements
and they are mentioned by many other
christians at this time most prominently
in our old friend irenaeus a bishop of
lyon who very harshly attacks what he
considers to be deviant forms of
christianity in his famous treaties
detection and overthrow of gnosis
falsely so-called sometimes known simply
as against the heresies
which was written around the year 180 he
calls out the gnostic heresies or school
of thought and all those inspired by
them like the valentinians as having
strayed from true christianity and
created a demonically inspired
abomination he traces all of these false
teachings back to a supposed teacher or
magician called simon magus or simon the
magician and that all their claims to
gnosis or true knowledge was in fact
false
keep in mind that the word heresy simply
means a school of thought at this time
and not necessarily
heresy as it is used today in fact it is
due to people like irenaeus and their
writings that that word came to have the
meaning that it has today that's a very
interesting side note in any case
irenaeus clearly isn't a fan of the
gnostics and yet his writings has been
one of the main sources that we've had
for their teachings and practices for
most of history and when we actually
read irenaeus's reports
it seems to align pretty well with the
writings by the gnostics themselves
which we now have since the discovery at
nag hamadi which shows that even though
he was a polemical writer who wanted to
discard the gnostics as heretics and to
his whole argument was that they were
wrong basically it seems that what he
wrote wasn't entirely untrue and that we
can rely to some degree on what he has
to say so in spite of his polemical
nature and the fact that he was so
critical irenaeus still remains one of
our main sources and most trustworthy
sources to this day irenaeus himself
clearly doesn't think that this group
has access to gnosis since this was a
positive term for most people at the
time so with this in mind we can be
pretty sure that he isn't the one who
gave them this name and that there was a
school of thought which appears to have
referred to themselves as the gnostics
it also appears that other groups like
the valentinians were actually the main
targets of irenaeus's critique
were not considered as part of this
gnostic school but were nonetheless of
course inspired by them this has led
many scholars to argue that this gnostic
school of thought as such identified by
irenaeus and others at the time should
be identified specifically with the
group that we today often called the
sethians or the sethian gnostics but who
were these gnostics or sethians then
what did they believe and how did they
practice to get to the bottom of these
questions we can look at two primary
kinds of sources those written by other
people like those by rnas for example
and sources written by the gnostics
themselves and luckily due to the
discovery at nag hamadi
the latter is actually possible today
out of all the texts found in this
collection there are a few that can with
some certainty be attributed to the
gnostic school more narrowly defined
most primary and influential of these is
the so-called secret book of john
sometimes called the apocrypha of john
but there are others like zostrianos the
foreigner the reality of the rulers and
the book of zoroaster
the very famous gospel of judas which
was actually later find not a part of
the nagamadi library as such is also
usually considered by scholars to belong
to the gnostics
one of the reasons these texts are
grouped together and connected to this
specific group is that their cosmic myth
is relatively consistent throughout
and it is to this myth that we now turn
the gnostic myth has become famous for
its complexity and the way it turns some
basic concepts of mainstream
christianity and judaism on its head
the world of the divine is vast it's a
vast divine world filled with many eons
and their relationship with each other
even quote unquote before the creation
of the material world which takes place
outside of time so before and after has
no meaning here but still even before
the creation of the material world this
complex pleiroma of many divine eons
known together as the entirety existed
in harmony the gnostics inherited the
conception of god and the divine from
antiquity and philosophy as a complex
realm rather than a stricter monotheism
as it later came to be conceived in any
case at the very top or center of this
divine realm what encompasses the whole
affair is the absolute and ultimate god
which is referred to with many names
such as the platonic one or monad or as
the father of the entirety and as the
invisible spirit
this god is understood in common
apathetic ways it is completely
unknowable it cannot be described or
understood in any way and yet it is the
source of everything and indeed the
reality in which everything takes place
quote the one is the invisible spirit we
should not think of it as a god or like
a god for it is greater than a god
because it has nothing over it and no
lord above it
it does not exist within anything
inferior to it since everything exists
within it for it established itself it
is eternal since it does not need
anything for it is absolutely complete
it has never lacked anything in order to
be completed by it rather it is always
absolutely completely in light
the one is illimitable since there is
nothing before it to limit it
unfathomable since there is nothing
before it to fathom it immeasurable
since there was nothing before it to
measure it
invisible since nothing has seen it
eternal since it exists eternally
unadorable since nothing could
comprehend it to utter it unnameable
since there is nothing before it to give
it a name
the invisible spirit is a kind of
intellect in other words in some way not
understandable to us it thinks about
itself and knows itself and in the
process of this thinking god is devolved
into the complex world of eons the
entirety already described
these eons are kind of like god's
thoughts about himself thus being both
identical to him but simultaneously also
somehow different
in the words of david brackie quote the
eons that make up the entirety result
from the invisible spirit's knowledge or
thought of itself
they are its thinking or its intellect
in all its complexity
they form also a spiritual realm the
equivalent of plato's realm of ideal
forms
for the gnostics the entirety that the
eons constitute is truly real and
eternal the material world is a flawed
imitation of the entirety and destined
to perish now all these eons which are
kind of like divine beings or divine
lights are named after certain divine
attributes the faint imitations of which
we can find in the material world
the first emanation or eon that appears
from the invisible spirit sometimes
known as the second principle is called
forethought or by the name of barbalo
quote his in other words the invisible
spirit thought became a reality and she
who appeared in his presence in shining
light came forth
she is the first power who preceded
everything and came forth from his mind
as the forethought of the all
her light shines like the father's light
she the perfect power is the image of
the perfect and invisible virgin spirit
she the first power the glory of barbalo
the perfect glory among the eons the
glory of revelation she glorified and
praised the virgin spirit for because of
the spirit she had come forth
she is the first thought the image of
the spirit she became the universal womb
for she precedes everything the barbalo
serves as the most central of the eons
from which all others then originate it
is also a feature that all gnostic
sources have in common whereas
everything beyond or after the barbalo
can differ between texts and
different authors but this second
principle is also very important for its
connection to christianity because it is
central to the idea of christ
in the secret book of john the barbalo
together with the invisible spirit
begets the self-originate or christ thus
forming a kind of family triad father
the invisible spirit mother the barbalo
and son christ
we will return more to the will of
christ in the gnostic myth later but
this self-originate or christ also
serves as a transitionary eon between
the barbalo and the rest of the
multitude of aeons that make up the
entirety and he is often described as
being the ruler over the rest of the
eons around this christ eon are four
luminaries referred to as harmosel
and eleleth which also contain the
archetypal human beings adam and his son
seth
from these four luminaries or eons stem
further eons and you can see how this
system is very complicated and hard to
grasp it is also important to remember
that the different gnostic texts give
different accounts on this divine realm
and it's eons so it's hard to say
anything definitive about the details
the eons are often numbered at 24 in
total and as mentioned earlier they are
named after and represents certain
attributes of god or the invisible
spirit
there are eons like truth
mind life and perhaps most importantly
for the gnostic myth wisdom or sophia in
greek even though all these eons are
seen as being beyond gender or
genderless they are often thought of as
existing in male female pairs which
complement each other
the eons are also semi-distinct in other
words they are all god in a general
sense but make up a more complex kind of
divinity than what we are used to today
now the very general and central part of
this myth
appears with one of these so-called
outermost eons that is wisdom or sophia
in the secret book of john it describes
how this wisdom eon or sophia wanted to
create something a thought of her own
but did so without the consent or
knowledge of her male counterpart
or asking permission from the great
invisible spirit court she wisdom wanted
to bring forth something like herself
without the consent of the spirit who
had not given approval without her
partner and without his consideration
the mail did not give approval
she did not find her partner and she
considered this without the spirit's
consent and without the knowledge of her
partner nonetheless she gave birth
this resulted in an imperfect creation a
misshapen pseudo-divine being that stood
outside of the divine world of the
entirety quote it did not resemble its
mother and was misshapen when sophia saw
what her desire had produced it changed
into the figure of a snake with the face
of a lion sophia was immediately very
ashamed of her actions and creation and
decided to hide it away from the rest of
the eons in a kind of cloud this being
was given the name yada baoth and is
sometimes also known by names like
suclas he aldeba oath himself in his
ignorance thinks that he is the only
divinity having little knowledge of the
true divine world
he thus proceeds to create an imperfect
and highly flawed world modeled after
the dim memory he has of the divine ple
roma
this world the creation of yaldaba oath
is the material world in which we live
and this is where the gnostics show
their radical departure from what we
consider mainstream christianity and
judaism today
the idea that the material world was
created by a divine being lower than the
highest god a demiurge or craftsman in
platonic language was taken for granted
at this time even by
monotheists but the idea that this
creator or this craftsman was ignorant
in some account even evil
was quite radical this also meant a
radical re-reading of biblical myths all
of this meant that the god of the whole
hebrew bible or the old testament to
christians the god described in genesis
as creating adam and eve the god who
sent the flood the god of the israelites
was not the true ultimate god it was
yaldaba
in the grand scheme of things the
material world becomes something very
negative
as a result of a grave mistake that must
be fixed a creation by an ignorant
imperfect foolish creator that is
keeping us prisoners indeed the human
being according to the gnostic myth has
a dual nature we are material beings
created by aldeba oath but the true
divine realm also helped us by tricking
yaldabaoth to quote blow his spirit into
adam so famously
said in the bible
which was really a way to infuse the
human being with the divine spark from
wisdom and from the rest of the eons
this allowed adam to stand up straight
and to challenge yaldabaoth and his
rulers in other words there is a
spiritual part of human nature that
comes from the true divine realm which
is also our ticket to get out of this
lesser material world after eve is
created she and adam have a number of
children
the famous cain and abel are conceived
through a kind of imperfect or impure
union when the spirit of eve leaves her
body and yeah the oath actually well he
actually rapes her which results in this
these two children but adam and eve have
another son called seth who is conceived
in a more pure way and seth becomes very
important for the gnostics seth is seen
as the bearer of gnosis or true wisdom
and as the kind of ancestor to the
gnostics themselves
so as you might know these gnostics at
least if we define them as narrowly as i
and some other scholars have here
sometimes or more often actually refer
to themselves as the seed of seth or
sometimes also known as the sethians and
this is because they trace their lineage
back to this character of seth who was
the sort of true son of adam and eve in
any case this creation story of course
differs very dramatically from the one
we're used to from mainstream
christianity so to say
for example the snake or serpent that
tempts eve and adam to eat from the tree
of knowledge to the gnostics is not
satan who tricks them but is actually
the
messenger from the divine world of the
pliroma the entirety who is actually
trying to help adam and eve to escape
from the creation of yada both so this
interpretation is completely turned
upside down it's the exact opposite of
the mainstream position many argue that
this idea of an ignorant false god comes
naturally from a reading or comparison
between the old and new testament even
today many who read these two collection
of texts are sometimes struck by the
seeming at least difference in
personality of god in these two
testaments or
scriptures so in the old testament for
example god seems a lot more
harsh like he orders the execution of
groups of people he sends down thunder
and and it's a lot of nasty stuff he's
very angry he's jealous all these kind
of characteristics while in the new
testament
he seems to emphasize other things like
love and compassion and so people like
the gnostics in antiquity
they also notice this seeming difference
and to them the only explanation for
this
weird difference in character must be
that these are in fact two different
gods one described in the old testament
or the hebrew bible which is the false
god yadaba oath and the true god who
sends jesus the invisible spirits of the
actual divine world the other oath in
all his ignorance and vanity wants his
creation to worship him only punishing
those who don't
exclaims in the hebrew bible quote for
my parts i am a jealous god and there is
no other god apart from me
which according to the secret book of
john paradoxically gives away the fact
that there is indeed another god called
for if no other one existed of whom
would he be jealous
human beings are caught in the
delusional prison that is the material
world but has the potential of escaping
to their true home
they need help in order to do so and
this is where jesus enters the picture
the gnostics were christians after all
and existed as a response to the life
and teachings of jesus of nazareth
considered to be the christ or anointed
one the savior of humanity again the
different texts differ on the nature of
christ as the incarnation of the cosmic
saber figure some like the first thought
in three forms seem to indicate that it
is the barbados herself who enters into
human form as jesus quote from my parts
i put on jesus i extracted him from the
accursed wood and i made him stand at
rest in the dwelling places of his
parents but we've also seen how the
secret book of john describes christ as
a divine eon in himself being begotten
from the invisible spirit and the
barbalo
the important part to know is that jesus
is a savior sent by the highest god the
true god in this case to save humanity
from the prison of the ignorant yaldaba
oath the gnostics have a significantly
different conception of jesus from the
later orthodox position
they professed a kind of dosetism that
is the idea that jesus did not actually
have a material body
it only seemed like he did and thus he
never suffered on the cross in any real
way
and if you know mainstream christian
theology you'll know that this goes
against some of its very fundamental
features
jesus's humanity and suffering is a
central part of the salvation narrative
but remember the gnostics saw the
material world in a very negative light
as the creation of a foolish pseudo-god
and thus didn't place the same emphasis
on the physical aspect
to the gnostics jesus didn't save
mankind by suffering on the cross he did
so by teaching them about gnosis about
the true knowledge of our real
identities and our essential home in the
divine realm of the entirety
christ was sent by the great invisible
spirit to remind humanity of our true
home and thereby help us escape the
shackles of material existence
quite a different version of events from
the orthodox narrative so this is where
the gnostics find themselves they are
the seed of seth those who have been
given the true teachings of christ
passed down from the apostles they
possess exclusive gnosis of the divine
reality which they can impart on the
initiate and this group made up a
significant part of the diverse world of
early christianity the practical aspects
of gnosticism are of course connected to
these very grand myths and theories and
even here they differ very dramatically
from mainstream christianity our sources
suggest that the gnostics did perform
some kind of baptism through water
a practice that was very common in
various religious traditions in
antiquity
this baptism is supposed to have
involved something referred to as the
five seals but scholars are unsure what
this actually means it is quite likely
that this baptism differed in many ways
from the
baptism ritual that we know from
mainstream christianity for example it
seems that the
gnostics would be baptized on multiple
locations perhaps
in in connection to reaching different
stations or or
levels on the spiritual path or the path
to back to the divine pleiroma
it's not entirely certain and indeed
this seems to be another major
characteristic of gnostic practice
different methods and techniques that
help the practitioner ascend into the
divine realm of different eons until
reaching the highest eon of the barbalo
and perhaps even contemplating the
invisible spirit itself quote the
gnostics believe that the human
intellect could experience gnosis that
is acquaintance with god within this
mortal life however fleetingly
they portrayed this experience primarily
as an ascent to higher knowledge that
was both intellectual and cosmic
intellectually the gnostic could ascend
by contemplating increasingly abstract
levels of existence starting by
understanding one's own existence and
that of other lower divine beings
advancing to the contemplation of higher
eons ultimately the barbalo and
attempting to gain some imperfect
acquaintance with the ineffable first
principle the invisible spirit
these practices seem to have involved a
kind of asceticism and studying of
mystical and philosophical works but
other than this we really find no
characteristic rituals associated with
the gnostics that survive at least
indeed they even outright rejected
certain
practices that other christians
performed like the eucharist which they
saw as foolish this becomes apparent in
the famous gospel of judas where jesus
scorns some of the apostles for
performing the eucharist and for doing
so they are ignorant and are worshiping
a false god rather than the correct one
in this gospel judas iscariot becomes
the only apostle who knows jesus true
identity when he exclaims quote you have
come from the mortal realm of the
barbalo but as for the one who sent you
i am not worthy to say his name
these doctrines practices and scriptural
interpretations set them apart from many
other early christians including people
like irenaeus and justin martyr who
would in later times be considered
orthodox or proto-orthodox but as talked
about earlier in the early period all of
these diverse movements had an equal
claim to be the quote-unquote true
christianity or of becoming orthodox the
gnostic school of thought often called
sethians appears to have been very
influential their ideas seem to have
been widespread across the roman empire
and influenced many other early
christians
this includes movements that are
sometimes included under the category of
gnosticism or broadly defined but which
doesn't fit the bill if we define the
term more narrowly as we have here
the valentinians for example associated
with the 2nd century teacher valentinus
from alexandria took a lot of
inspiration from the gnostic myths but
modified them using more clearly
christian terminology
texts from the nagamadi attributed to
the valentinians include the gospel of
truth and the tripartite treatise which
showcase a lot of similarities with the
gnostic myth albeit a bit simplified the
worldview of the valentinians were not
as outright negative as that of gnostics
and seems a bit more explicitly monistic
they also seem to have blended in with
the rest of the christians much more
going to the same churches and
congregations only meeting for special
meetings to be taught the particularly
valentinian aspects of the teachings
indeed in irenaeus's against the
heresies it is the valentinians who are
his main target of critique and concern
probably because they outwardly appeared
like any other christians but according
to him harbored heretical teachings in
secrets and invited unsuspecting
christians into their study circles
similarly the anatolian martian and the
marcia knights also share a lot of
features with the gnostics including the
complex divine realm the pseudo god or
demiurge that created the material world
etc however the creator god was not
ignorant or evil according to marcion
but quotes unrelentingly just and the
highest god is he referred to as the
stranger rather than the invisible
spirit
marcion is created with being the first
christian to attempt to create a
canonical new testament including a
modified version of the gospel of luke
and a few of the pauline letters and he
differs from the gnostics not the
related groups by denying the hebrew
bible or old testament entirely
so while the gnostics saw the old
testament as somewhat misguided in its
praise of the false yadava oath they
still saw it as useful for teaching
purposes but marcion just rejected its
use completely there are other groups
and thinkers clearly inspired by the
gnostic school of thought in this early
period all of whom we can dedicate
separate episodes to but the gnostic
school of thought in particular stands
out as a very fascinating expression of
the jesus movements
as christianity became the imperial
religion of the roman empire an official
orthodoxy was established in the
different church councils over time the
gnostic school disappears from the
historical record
they did not survive these developments
at least not explicitly
but indeed we find remnants of the
gnostics in later developments and
movements as well
the religions of manichaeism and
mandaism share a lot of features with
the gnostics and even later in the
middle ages there are groups like the
cathers in western europe whose
teachings may connect in some way to the
gnostic school or at least to certain of
the ideas that they held and as with so
many other ancient religions we find a
kind of resurgence of interest in
gnosticism today from youtube channels
reddit forums and university courses
it all testifies to an increased
interest and fascination with this
ancient quote-unquote heresy the fact
that people even today actually identify
as gnostics and as wanting to revive
this ancient form of christianity shows
just how
complex the religious environment of
today and really all times and places
are and that every religion and
religious movements are engaged in
constant flux and development
if you want to support this channel that
you can do so by becoming a monthly
patron or by
giving a one-time donation and i will
leave links to all of that in the
description or you can just simply like
subscribe and comment on this video
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you